I'm advocating for the
components of video games,
especially the engaging ones,
to be ported into classroom
instruction because the audience,
the students,
clearly understand the medium.
Video games contain the
blueprint for engagingeducation
because of the way that they
cater to human learning,
a complex story interwoven
with learning content
and a bit of artificial intelligence
for difficulty and balance.
Onlineinstruction can be enhanced if
schools turn to top streaming platforms
and streamers
to learnhow to effectively
engage students online.
And the objectives for education overall
need tobe as specific as a video game
so that those who are enrolled
have a clear line of sight
towhere they're headed.
If we can start showing students
how their passion for playing
connectsto their futures,
we will have done our jobs